so first of all i saw hunter hunter that
ending
whole that was a lot right how did you
react
yeah how did you react when you read
that so when i read it
it was it wasn't um it was good it was
definitely powerful
reading it but but seeing it put
together because i wasn't there
was mind-blowing it was it was uh they
executed it
so well no pun intended um
it's it's it's great i mean people we
release the
the trailer and you know the synopsis
and whatnot and people have
an idea of what they think they have an
idea of what the movie is about
and it it really no one's really hit it
yet
um so i mean the ending's awesome
yeah i mean i was just really intrigued
by the whole film and then that ending
yeah it was just like that icing on the
cake is like
wow like you will remember this movie um
what was it overall about this film that
you were really intrigued about
the the writing was
it was it was a page turner it was um it
was it was
it was a good read good dialogue good
scenes um
camille sullivan was already on and i
was aware of her
you know how powerful of an actress she
is um
you know so i knew it was going to be a
good project then i spoke to the
director and
and uh everything just seemed to fit
really
yeah okay now during this whole pandemic
have you ever thought about just going
out with your whole family into the
woods and just living in a cabin like in
this movie hunter hunter is that a big
no
no the the i'm a city guy i i
i mean i come from canada but still i i
like the city and and i like the comfort
of all that stuff
so this was i really had to um figure
out how to be this guy i i mean the
director
well i got the script a week before we
started shooting it so there wasn't a
lot of prep time
so i had to trust the director a lot in
in
uh in becoming a guy that that's that's
cool to be out there and and uh
knows what he's doing um but for me now
i i couldn't do it
i couldn't do it so it was a little bit
yeah i don't think i could do it either
it's too much man too much
right yeah yeah too unpredictable um you
are so much fun to follow on twitter
you have a huge following you tweet
every day number of times a day
how how much fun do you have connecting
with people like all over the world
well it's been especially nice during
the pandemic because i've been doing the
whole quarantine thing i've been trying
to stay in as much as i can trying to
get this thing under control
so twitter's kind of like especially
since i'm away from my family it's kind
of like an
another way to communicate with people
and
and you know um and keep me occupied
i suppose keep me out of trouble um
look i love it i like twitter it's it's
a lot of fun
and people want to hear from you they
want your opinions and you give out your
opinions like you're not afraid to hold
back and that's what's kind of fun about
following you i think i've gotten in
trouble a few times i think i've i've uh
i've stepped over the line on a few
occasions
um but uh yeah i like to just be as
as much of me as i possibly can on
twitter and and not be boring and
and you know just say what i think and
and hopefully the way i think is right
and and you know that's what it is
yeah and now it's fun okay so obviously
this just happened over the weekend
what was your reaction to snl christmas
themed parody
of course it's so good so snl does this
christmas themed parody of the stan
music video
pete davidson was so good in it what was
your reaction
so i saw i think i saw it a lot
differently than other people did
because pete davidson not only
um he not only did the video but
he got all the nuances everything from
blowing the pencil off
um to some of the eye rolls at certain
moments
he nailed it he absolutely nailed it um
20 years later and someone decides to
parody the stan video
uh flattering um again man i
to be a part of that song uh the fact
that eminem picked me
uh and that it's still as powerful today
it's it's flattering uh they killed it
they absolutely
killed it um i laughed i smiled um
good job snl yeah and then eminem did a
bit of a cameo at the end which was
awesome
yeah yeah um when
people come up to you and want to talk
about different projects that you've
been in
you know throughout your whole career
what do they talk to you the most about
what do they want to know the most about
it depends on who's coming up to me yeah
like for if it's
you know if it's a 30 year old uh woman
30 to 40 year old woman you know usually
it's it's something to do with either
casper
or now and then um so that's me yeah
yeah um and then i get you know then i
get a different crowd you know the
stoner crowds want to talk about you
know the the idol hands and
and it's i've done so many weird
different things that i get
i get a a variety of different people
that have their favorite kind of
thing that i've i've done um but uh
casper's never gonna die i've i've come
to terms with that
um it's uh
it's it's part of who i am i suppose
that that
two days i worked on it um was
was is just you know that's that i get
that a lot and uh
of course stan and final destination and
yeah um
you posted this amazing video of your
son watching you and casper for the
first time is that their favorite movie
of yours
you know my kids
they're not feeling my movies too much
um
the first one i tried i don't know i i
tried to put wild americom and they
looked at me like i was
crazy um i don't know if it just didn't
age properly or the
puppets the bear puppets running around
they're so spoiled with with technology
and like things like the lion king and
you know jungle book being so amazing
that they see this guy running around a
bear
thing it's just like dad what is this i
think they'll be
i mean they're just they're six and four
right now so yeah anything comes out of
their mouth they're like dad this sucks
will come out of your mouth
because they don't know that that i'm a
little hurt by that
um but i that's it they i tried weld
america that was a no-go
casper he saw and you know
i guess they liked it um but that's
that's all they've
that's all they've seen there's a lot of
movies they can't see for a long time
that's true that's true is there a movie
that you've done that you don't want
them to see or
just when they get to the right age then
you'll show them everything i'm having a
hard time with some of the movies i've
done in the past where there's
you know scenes with uh with with
other actresses that you know i
they have to understand i guess because
i don't know it just feels weird you
know yeah me and
and uh so they've got to be at the right
age to understand that stuff
um but uh i mean i'm sure there's a
couple of snoozers that i don't want
them to see
i did some i did movies in the in the
mid 2000s that
man i don't want anybody to see them
that's amazing um well speaking of
casper because obviously this
film will never die it's like one of my
go-to's every halloween um have you ever
thought about doing like a zoom reunion
with christina ricci because it would
just mean so much to so many people
uh never say never i suppose uh but you
gotta understand that the
the uh malachi pearson was the was the
guy that uh
played the voice for the for casper he
did the voice for the entire thing so
i i he's he he did the heavy lifting for
that movie and i came in for two days
because he was a little bit younger than
christina
and and it didn't work out and so they
needed somebody because the original
that ending ended up wasn't in the
original script
so i mean i'd be open to it i'd be open
to it but you know i don't want to step
on uh
malachi's toes and and over overstep
because he really did do the hard work
yeah no no that makes sense um so are
you working on a movie right now i feel
like you've been posting some stuff out
like behind the scenes
yeah i'm doing yeah so i did this movie
idol hands
uh and there's the whole hand thing and
that movie we all came from
an actor named bruce campbell who
everybody knows uh his evil dead 2
performance
and so i'm doing a movie with him and
i'm like the biggest fan boy on set
there is like i just every time i see my
smile and like remember because he was
such
like i was 12 years old watching those
movies and and uh
we're doing a movie about uh crazy
christmas shoppers they get possessed by
aliens and it's it's
comedy horror you know we got
an amazing special effects team and uh
yeah we're doing it in boston which is
which is a whole other thing because
boston some of my favorite accents some
of my favorite people
um it's been a blast oh that's awesome
um the army of darkness was like the big
movie in my family that we always
watched with bruce campbell right so
that was like the big one in my house
yeah
he's so cool on set too he's so so
giving and nice and
and uh it's been a real treat